[Music]
everyone welcome to the top six
i'm quincy larson with free code camp i
am joined by matt filming CEO and
co-founder of nella phi cool comport the
CEO and co-founder of forms free and
chris anderson the lead developer
evangelist for for fana the database so
today we are going to be talking with a
lot actually seven I said top six but
actually we decided to extend it to a
seventh one because we were so bowled
over by the quality of the submissions
we're gonna be talking with seven teams
of hackathon participants many of whom
did not know one another 36 hours ago
came together they built some amazing
stuff and we're gonna see that amazing
stuff and we're gonna get to the bottom
of how they built it and who they are so
first we're gonna start with caption
this and gentlemen perhaps we can start
with you just quick introductions who
you are where you're from what you do my
name is Vijay I'm from New Hampshire and
I actually am a technician I work for GE
aviation so as a technician and I just
graduated from the Granite State College
yeah that's what I do and I love coding
great Thank You Vijay welcome and
congratulations on reason thank you I'm
a David Carter I just moved to San
Francisco in July
and originally from the Antelope Valley
Palmdale Lancaster and right now I work
at a WordPress agency and so I'm looking
to get more into reaction gem stuff
great are you a Broncos fan
hi my name is summit I'm a QA engineer
and I live in Sunnyvale California I
actually started learning friend and
development at free code camp so this is
for me and yeah I'm continuing to learn
more of front-end like react and other
free books so yeah I'm really excited
thank you so much
well perhaps you could go ahead and give
us a very quick demonstration of how
captionthis works
all right so caption this is basically
gonna present you with a random gift so
every time you load the page it's gonna
get a random gift so if you don't like
it you could always press this next
button and you could choose better gifts
and so you can enter in any caption you
want submit it and it's gonna add it to
our list of submitted gifts and every
user could whether or not you submit a
gif you can upvote and we're gonna rank
all these submissions by votes so the
most popular will always be at the top
and we've added authentication with
identify
right on you've got some pretty cool
gifts here to hand very good captions
for someone what's your favorite so far
that you what is what
caption are you most proud of so far
[Music]
where do you get the gifts from the ABI
is called Jaffe so where do you stand on
like gift versus Jeff pronunciation
everybody who pronounces a gift say woo
Ready Set whoo everybody who pronounces
it Jeff say woo actually I like to call
it gif great well judges what do you all
think so far it's great I really love
this one I think it's fun I think it's
kind of a cool I like that you can
upvote it and then everyone can see that
it's participatory it's kind of it's
cool there's a good scope a lot of times
hack apps will over scope or under scope
and it's hard to be impressive like that
but it's impressive to bring it mostly
to completion because you picked the
right scope yeah yeah I would
certainly share that opinion I've seen
so many hackathon projects that are
extremely ambitious and they have to
pare back all their ambitions right
before the demo time but it looks like
this is something that was definitely
doable within the time frame and yeah
and you are thank you - great
did you have any sort of top things you
would have liked to do that there wasn't
time from that you had to scope back
from or there is a we wanted to tie
Bodeen to user authentication right now
we're just storing that waste local
storage so taya until the user would
have been nice
storage this matter of gradual way of
getting there you imagine you'll keep
hacking on it
um maybe and what kind of collaborative
filtering method are you thinking about
are you thinking about like a like
reddit or hacker news or some of those
other collaborative filtering algorithms
and or how are you planning for things
to gradually decay and fall off of the
top of that activity well I mean there
are plenty of models I just wanted to
see if you were all over thinking about
it cuz you don't want the top part of
thing to always be on the top because it
alone should be fresh we should have
some tabs on there so recent ones or pop
most popular tabs that how did you split
up the work between you so he rejected
all the styling stuff yeah all the CSS
and he did all the JavaScript part and I
was there for like adding features
sometimes and also for like running
around and like yeah problems with wanna
DB or forms free which we had those two
guys about how do we go forward what
should we do and all those things yeah
we had great help so we'd like to thank
all the judges and their during the
hackathon process it was pretty great
without them we couldn't even complete
this for sure right what have you
learned from this hackathon that you
didn't know at the beginning about
yourself for me like I was you know as I
said I was coding in a free code camp
online thing so I had I never worked as
a team I never caught it as team so it's
really a different experience I believe
and
I really learned a lot of stuffs and how
team you know goes up so I really
learned a lot about the teaming flame
first the first most thing and about you
know reading documentation that those
things were very important and because
the API is reused here and the databases
we used they were completely new for us
but you know the sizes they showed us -
where to go for the technical
documentation so we just wait that and I
think because of that so yeah we learned
probably 30 ask collaboration skills
working with people and different skill
sets and learning to divide the work so
everyone works to their advantages we
didn't know each other before these
hackathon until yesterday we didn't know
each other
I'm from New Hampshire all the way from
New Hampshire and yep so we just made a
team and are there other apps you almost
built no we'd even have an idea for this
that's kind of spur of the moment at
what point did you start shift from like
idea and conceptualization and and
building your team like it what hour of
yesterday would you say you actually sat
down the started Tony probably after
lunch yeah
any other questions why what's the
hottest thing you had to solve while
building this the login because we just
have limited time to last hour yeah
incrementing the votes mmm
learning how to like we had to read and
write yeah yeah dr. Wong on TV like how
would you do yeah well great thank you
so much for coming up here and for
demoing pleasure meeting you three
gentlemen and I'm very impressed before
you've done here great girl
just let me know when the audios back
okay great yeah so wall wall hacks fees
coming up here go ahead it's situated I
just want to take a moment to recognize
be careful that all right so I just want
to take a moment to acknowledge one of
the biggest sponsors of the event I
guess maybe the mr. but natla Phi is
such an amazing supporter of the
developer community and they're really
pushing forward with a lot of technology
that's gonna make the internet faster
and safer and make it easier for
organizations to scale their website so
Matt bellman from nella Phi is a
visionary and I'm very excited
personally to see where where he goes
and where natla Phi goes in the coming
years so thanks again for your support
thanks thanks for having me here and
thanks for helping bring all of this on
and driving it forward and from building
free code camp I think everything we do
is about helping developers build things
so being at a place and seeing hundreds
of developers building things with alle
thyng it's really exciting and on the
note of people building things using
nella Phi let's talk to XP how are you
well
oh we started starting with this
gentleman we'll just go just tell us
your name where you're from and what
you're doing with your time these days
all right well my name is Robert wolf
I'm originally from Europe but I'm
taking my extension mr. here studying UX
design but I also like to code and when
I discovered gems tag about a year ago I
so one of the first keynotes I was so
excited was like telling all my friends
stop doing what you're doing start doing
the new way and I'm so happy to be here
today where it actually kind of have
grown and I feel like there's a lot of
people around
doing the same thing great hi I'm Ann
ill I was no software developer here in
Bahia and I have I'm real excited about
that react stuff and all then I got to
know about the Gatsby stuff and I have
build some kind of local projects with
me and then I got to know more about the
jam stack and was really exciting so I
don't know who out there is working on
that and I got when I bought the
saxophone it's pretty good environment
out here yeah Ron so my name is Kyle
Smith and I'm a student at CSU
Stanislaus career science student and
yeah just started learning about web
technologies when I was in high school
and found out about Jam stack a lot like
a few months ago and it was just so easy
to grasp and just been interested ever
since great my name is Mona Liz and I'm
a computer science student and Cabrillo
based in Center crease and honestly I
don't remember how I came across free
code camp I came across it thankfully
and I've been programming ever since
okay I'm Brian wiemer I live here in
Oakland in the Bay Area and I actually
work as a project slash Account Manager
so I like these kind of opportunities
because I've never known a hackathon
before but I thought the awesome to get
my hands dirty in the code and I really
like the Jam stack I've built the number
of you know personal websites with it
and it's such a contrast from like the
monolithic things that I'm used to in
the enterprise world you know doing it
for a big client it's really refreshing
to do something like this please James
thank you yeah well Ryan it looks like
you're at the helm yeah let me know if
we can discipline we blew it
it's pimenta I'm plugging to plug it in
again okay classical
[Music]
oh good good night all right here we go
here we go let's make that fullscreen so
as you already know our name is Haxby
we're on the hackathon using Gatsby this
is the problem we're solving if you ever
learned a language with a language app
you know it's a terribly boring and kind
of weird process usually starett of
pictures of people you've never seen
before and try to attach your basic
vocabulary to the pictures it doesn't
really work I've tried to learn a
language of many different apps I've
never succeeded so when we came here
together and the hackathon without we
gonna make something that it would be
gonna approach learning a language
differently and what we realized is that
it's all about you they what makes the
learning language easier if is if you
can relate if your brain can associate
things with it so we wanted to make
something relatable and also fun and
that's why we created new lingual oh
well you willing will does is it takes
your Instagram images and teaches you
new vocab based on them no this is our
app works so at first we authorize
Instagram then we take the pictures from
the Instagram and in a real time we pass
them through the clarify data to get
image recognitions and get an idea about
what is it in yeah
now clarify API returns this words the
tags of the images in different
languages so we pull it out in a
different language of the user that he
selected and we play a quiz with them
that's how we teach them the words now
this is how the quiz looks like so you
have the word fruit oh that's for
example through it and Italian and you
have four pictures from your Instagram
feed this is my own feels embarrassing
and you have to select the one that is
and thanks to clarify API being
available in 23 different languages we
can offer this frog in 23 languages very
easily so that's exciting now we're
gonna show you a quick demo about how it
actually works
all right so this is the demo that we
had showed before so this is a little
bit more limited in terms that we wanted
to show Spanish specifically and again
with Robert but just to kind of give you
a idea and some of these words you know
there's obviously room for improvement
mess Camino I'm asking it could be a lot
of these right okay time ran out so that
was an example oh yeah select great one
we have a response for a good job Beach
if I select the wrong one sorry
incorrect and we're also totaling your
scores and kind of have some logic
involved with that fruto an example and
then basically we give you score that we
total and we give you an ability to
tweet out your results you know I did
great on you know my my test in Spanish
with my own selfie there we kind of
leave it up to the user and how they
want to promote it but that's kind of
our way of cross promoting them another
cool idea we thought was like this is
such a new thing and they're probably
all sorts of bugs and ways to improve it
we want to give an ability to add some
feedback right so using forms free we're
able to simply you know add a way to
give your name email what's your
feedback how can we make our app better
can send it and and actually send it
that's what some dummy data obviously
but yeah you get the idea right and
forms free makes are really easy and
something that we're really excited
about is that's what we were showing
before and already we were already kind
of hacking away even in the short time
we had like let's add some more
languages right so they're already doing
that let's add German so we're already
working on making that improved so it's
just cool that we do so much more with
it so that's an example of German
instead of Spanish and with my Instagram
feed so you were able to get Instagram
integrated or did you see the data so so
that was the biggest job the eye experts
can talk about this initially when we
thought about the Instagram thing right
we thought the privacy forces will be
there and all and we couldn't get the
Gator and all so then we figured out
that there is a API there out there but
the only constant refused is
the sandbox API which allows only 10
users initially and each user will have
only 20 pictures from their XI so that's
how we are looking right now but when
you have a full-fledged app we can send
for the Instagram access so that it can
be expanded to a number of users so
that's what we are working on yeah so
that's one kind of problem we faced here
the product looks great yeah you've done
a good job of just keeping the number of
elements to an absolute minimum and it's
colorful big elements so I definitely
commend your design sensibilities
collaborating is great kind of like pair
programming splitting the API group
actually the API group and the front-end
group so that the nos can be divided
easily and the integration had some
hiccups but what was the planning like
did you sit down and think about I mean
how did you how did you choose the
problem to solve and then how did you
set about choosing Instagram and machine
learning to solve it well so we actually
get hurt on Friday on a disk or chip so
we didn't have any idea and we start
deciding on Saturday morning um we were
very fascinated with the clarify API we
thought well this is such a powerful
thing we can do so many thanks to that
at first we thought about helping
visually impaired people and then we
have this idea of languages and it just
seemed like a such a fun concept and a
lot of things to do with that by noon we
know this is what we're going with
how did you select sort of the scope for
their app and where there's some things
you felt like I really wanted those in
but first thought about that price we
thought like many of the kids apps are
like this like suppose when you go to
school right you learn about a fruit or
something by seeing that and you learn
the language like that but when we
thought about Instagram it came out out
of the blue and then we got in about
adults as well and
language as well and that's how yeah we
thought this would be more personal to
the user then using some random images
exactly using Instagram was kind of the
key idea yeah make us excited because
everyone loves themselves they'll have
pictures it's just gonna be it exit to
his gameis vo we stopped developing
yesterday yeah we definitely ran into
two items with scope right I mean
thinking about it's like project
management right you know we rented lots
of cool features that we wanted to so we
actually had a whiteboard catalyst like
these are problems these are some kind
of features and we tried to address the
problems before the future features we
wanted out sound that's really cool but
that's probably lower priority than are
you all concerned that at some point
after playing the game a little bit that
you're gonna kind of be seeing the same
images I mean I have a somewhat active
Instagram feed but probably not more
than 50 images in there and I can
imagine that I won't be able to learn
all of German with other public users
images to be seen so that's one kind of
privacy policy they have but other thing
is that it can I think it has an end
point where we can get the data from a
specific location I'mI'm glad you're
doing it dude
so that might work so that's kind of one
of the enhancement we thought about but
yeah so you can't like get images from
friends or anything unfortunately due to
privacy would have been much easier
three years ago
it's a little bit more difficult now on
the other hand clarify gives us a list
of 20 words per image so we could
basically if you have three images you
mister lin 60 words is that extensible
can you add like can you teach clarify
more so right now we're just using their
general model we haven't really explored
in there I hope we could maybe develop
our own model based an Instagram
pictures a lot of selfies right yeah
that's a good point
have you considered maybe expanding the
functionality by encouraging people to
take more photos on Instagram and hey
maybe you should take a picture of fruit
could also teach you to be a good
photographer that way photography
projects and language projects
application one more thing that's
important say for us it's important it's
a website no no because this is
something people will go and try out
really quickly and that's where the
power of James eggs coming
so because opens up instantly and with
one click you can start and play we also
will save data into local stories so
when the user visits again they will
have their app already open is it mobile
friendly is this thing all right yeah I
mean because the design is pretty basic
we didn't have to do too much on the
quiz itself you did make it somewhat
friendly as much as we can you know
design
have you considered talking to language
teachers to get feedback on how this
could be used how this could be improved
so none of us is actually personal
experience cuz Robert has learned I'm
sure what other next moves would be
helpful to be very excited needs push
notifications to remind me it's time to
study yeah and to remind you to take
Instagram photos of things and when you
go to your next country you can talk to
your friends in different language about
you
[Laughter]
yeah well I would encourage you to
continue pursuing it I'm not like an
expert and he would psychology or
anything but the vanity angle and the
way the brain works and stuff it may
actually be more compelling and form
stronger relations if it's something
personally related to you then you're
associating that word with so thank you
gentlemen for coming in thanks for
building this excellent application in
such a short time it's very impressive
and yeah well we'll look forward to
hearing more about what you do and the
coming months and if if you do continue
working on this let us know because we'd
like to see how it comes along and maybe
do catch up and do a retrospective on
awesome all right thank you all right
and next team is going to be makes what
I'm very excited about makes why also
very excited about thank you so much
gold coal again CEO and co-founder of
forestry Cole Krum Holt and thanks for
all the guidance you purvey provided to
the many participants here you have
truly created a great developer
experience as far as installing forms
and forms are a big deal and pretty much
every developer has to deal with forms
and I'm really excited to hear that
you're so rapidly
like development is the team who
couldn't make it here they were working
really hard up until like pretty much
the last minute and it was great we got
a lot of good stuff down at the end
including an entire redesign of site
which yeah it was a great forcing
function for us to get a lot of stuff
done I think now we're gonna probably do
some cleanup okay all right well good
luck fandoms are technical day here we
are with our next very exciting team
first of all before we get started I
just want to say that this was
incredibly well presented I think all of
us agreed that your delivery was
phenomenal so we're looking forward to
hearing a little bit more that don't
agree here but make squad let's start
let's start with you faith and perhaps
you can introduce yourself and then we
keep and I go around and clockwise and
definitely so I'm faith and I'm a
student at make school so hence the name
make squad and yeah so we have some
other people here on the team as well
yeah before we do if you could just tell
us like where you're from and aside from
being a student it makes cool I'm like
just a little bit about your background
sure um so I'm from Atlanta and I moved
out to San Francisco to attend make
school right now I'm working on back-end
web development as my primary
concentration but I was interested in
this hackathon because the opportunity
to work kind of more in the front end
and exercise that skill a little bit and
I was excited by all of the api's and I
also have an interest in things that
have to do with machine learning and we
did employ a little bit of the clarify
API in here so that was really fun to
work with them to see how that works
yeah yes I'm - Shari Boucher
Southern California I've been in San
Francisco for about two years and I came
here to do to be a chaplain in the
hospital but after my residence a year I
wanted to do like a combination of both
the tech and the social services so my
ultimate goal is to try to have a
nonprofit for young adults who've been
mentally or physically abused in
childhood and to help them with the
trade like solar coating and to be able
to like so they can have a better
lifestyle after having a smoke
I guess whether use and so this
hackathon is a great experience for me
to get experience to network with
different people and to meet these
wonderful people who make school and um
graciously welcomed me into a team from
Georgia also in make school and moved
here about four months ago and well I
worked with coating off and on for like
the last ten years but nothing really
serious until I moved here but it's
always been a passion of mine and I had
a lot of fun at this hackathon learning
these new technologies great I'm
Jonathan and I'm a full-stack developer
I'm a school and I'm from Houston Texas
okay hi I'm Stephanie I'm a junior in
school so I just started a couple months
ago I'm in August and I'm from Miami
I've done also free camp like a couple
of people here as well and it was great
I've also done one hackathon before and
it was it was great it was stressful too
but there the end product was great was
it lovely I love building products yeah
and since you all are from make school
perhaps just a quick word about make
school because it is a new educational
model yeah so it's a new education model
and it is product based learning so
basically instead of attending a lot of
long boring lecture
and writing stuff on the whiteboard for
hours and kind of getting and entrenched
in the theory of it we build products
throughout the term you build a product
at the end of every term we have like
our own mini hackathon it's an intensive
where you build a product in a week we
work on teams we work individually so
throughout the time that you attend the
program you're building up a portfolio
and so that's why a lot of us were
interested in doing this hackathon
because we wanted to have another
opportunity to build something to yeah
to ship it get our idea out there yeah
and how long is the program mix schools
two years and it is a bachelor's program
so it's an accelerated bachelors
we have some people who attend for about
a year and then they get hired out of
the program but it's a two-year long
program great so at the end of the
program you all have if you're looking
for novel higher education models sounds
like this might be worth so not further
ado let's jump to the demo you ready
let's do it yeah
so our app is called network you can
leave your business card at home because
your face is your business card and so
we thought a lot about you know what it
feels like sometimes when you're at
these networking events especially
because the world is full of a lot of
emerging technologies sometimes you
forget those business cards or its
clunky to kind of like you know waffle
with those and so our idea was to build
an app where you can simply take a photo
of somebody or you can take a video of
them and you can use that video or that
photo to retrieve their virtual business
card to get back their information so we
built kind of a Minimum Viable Product
here that demonstrates that idea and
we're hoping to have a chance to develop
it further in the future but for now we
do want to start with the app and so
this is the business part info you would
go ahead and fill in name your email
address your phone number your state
city and state and then you can
and fill in your LinkedIn we would also
have Twitter which would be an optional
field and then an other field where you
could fill in additional information and
then you could submit that but before we
go to the submission page we also
connected a contact form here so the
people who people have questions for
people who have ID you know ideas for
new features or for people who have
problems using the app they can ping us
we used forms free to connect the
contact form and this form actually does
work it does submit and we get the email
from that so we could get updated
information there and then of course
that went through a couple of
submissions from this IP address over
there and then four so we got two sides
or two ways to to go ahead and check
check out the database you can go to
camera first and you want to go to video
and so then you just select the image so
for now we're using the celebrity model
of the API because it was already hooked
up to like a model but ideally we would
be able to use user photos in the future
it goes to the database we used fana DB
for the database and we used to clarify
for the API that's the celebrity model
that we're using here and then it would
bring back the person's information we
have Leonardo DiCaprio and we got Kanye
as our tests great and earlier you you
were able to use a phone could you do
that just to show
the image recognition will work from
another device all right all right work
whatever worked
yeah great demo thanks for going through
it questions how did you know that this
is the happy one who makes I didn't
settle into the idea well we're kind of
talking about it
Oh while we're coming into the building
on the first day and we like bounce
ideas around and more about the ideas
hackathon how at what point did you
start working and this specific idea so
when we first started out we we had been
taught that um you actually have to plan
first before you start even coating so
we didn't start coding until like the
middle of the day and so we started with
user stories to try to make sure we we
had to have to do it as supposed to do
and we had we even used parts of github
like the project's page where you have a
Kanban board and you can move the the
the cards over once you've been it's
been completed so I think that's about a
good way to plan so that way you can
know whether what you're you want to do
is actually done yeah and I can testify
that we use github projects all the time
that's fine when you can move this the
cards over it's like crossing it off
your lids ya know organize your work how
did you decide like team which team was
the front-end back in like I think we
all played on our assurance I know
that's like one of the first things that
we access like what are you good at and
we divided it up that way and we had
some very strong and Bekins like she
said that make school focuses on
back-end but they also quote I guess
focus on full stack so really one for
front-end specialist or
and so just and really everybody just
chipping in we're you know or their
select giving or if someone was
struggling they move about in any of the
areas you all did a great job with the
design you know it's like you know pink
and blue I think they're complementary
colors like if you look at like a color
wheel and very minimalist design you can
see like a little element that kind of
flourish up there with the rounded
raindrop shapes just making sure it
worked and it was cohesive on every
single page as well so yeah we had we
had some some ideas about what we wanted
and the way what we wanted to look we
did want it to be Manila so I'm glad you
said that
we also wanted I I was really a fan of a
lot of color in the background like so
we can market to people who are are
networking and starting off in their
careers yeah for the modern kind of
professional yeah definitely like looks
like something that would get acquired
by LinkedIn
on that note are you are you kind of I
said Minimum Viable Product before and I
think it would be good for us to
continue development on it so that we
can get it hooked up and get users
actually in there to make sure that this
is something that people would use that
people would enjoy using yeah actually
we haven't done any user testing so we
don't even know if this is this could be
good for them you know it could just be
a product and it doesn't go
anywhere so we have to check our market
as well ice age observation and I can
tell you I don't carry business cards
people often ask for them people being
over those now you'll be able to say my
face is my business guy thank you again
so much for coming in and demoing this
and building it and it sounds like you
all are from all over the US
congratulations on converging and
forming a team and you know jiving so
cohesively yeah it's amazing so yeah
thanks again and we're looking forward
to hearing about how things go future
economic in to our six or seven games
that we're gonna talk and this time I
want to talk about Chris Anderson he is
the director of developer of vandalism
at fauna and I interviewed this guy
yesterday and I don't know that I've
ever talked to somebody who's worked
with so many different types of
databases it's so young he's definitely
got an encyclopedic knowledge of the
sequel databases and also knows a lot
about real-world implementation
and the trade-offs associated with
different eyes Chris thank you so much
for coming here and aspiring everybody
and sharing your knowledge and also
thanks to you and fauna for sponsoring
this event
oh yeah I really enjoy like the little
bits of ways to help people get unstuck
when they're hacking like to me that's
the fun part
yeah well um our next team is Phoebe in
jams yeah all right so you all have a
nice posture all right I think it's nice
it's got a little more character to it
yeah you think it's a doctor Kent here
it's up there you can have like you know
like I think it's like game faq says
like the character face-off and last
year like Tetris L block one saves the
day yeah we should have someone like
that starting with you why don't you
tell us a little bit your self we're
gonna move in a clockwise since we got
two rows here okay yeah okay so my name
is Vince I'm a native San Franciscan
born and raised and I guess I'm aspiring
over uh you know currently looking for
work yeah that's pretty much it hi my
name is Jin like gin and tonic like
alcohol I'm also a native San Franciscan
like Vince I'm also using free code camp
to learn and try to learn how to program
I have a background so sysadmin but I
want to make that leap into the
development space and so that's my first
hackathon and trying to learn as much as
possible all right next write my name is
Brian Stinson I am NOT a developer I'm
curly in the Air Force I had 13 years
this month just to kind of learn
something new for Reforma get out
a couple years left and want to be a
developer so but learning was free
cocaine but a couple of the resources
and it's my first hackathon awesome yeah
my name is Ruben um
nominated San Franciscan but I move from
those four yeah uh I'm not a developer
either I'm a mechanical engineer and
then I transitioned over to electrical
hi now I'm just trying to transition
over to software and so yeah I used I
start with free code camp so thank you
klitzy
but yeah just been working on react and
it's also my first hackathon it's been
just a ton of fun like getting to talk
with the sponsors it's cool
yeah and I'm Austin and I yeah I got
during Korean Chemical Engineering
decided I wanted to switch to software
engineering and so yeah I relied heavily
on free code camp for that and and now I
work at QAPI which is a start-up in San
Mateo and so I have a open source
project
you don't know JavaScript exercises and
run a meet-up or react meetup in
Berkeley so Wow so look at lunch and
varied backgrounds although
disproportionately from San Francisco
well tell us a little bit so yeah so go
ahead the app so it's sick pics so yeah
what sick pics is is it's a game for
anyone who can anyone can play so right
now so we have this created game button
or you can click and create a game right
now there's a button below this has no
games available but if there's a game
available then anyone can join join a
random game that someone else has
created and what the game is
is once it starts you could have any
number of people that have joined that
game and you need to take a picture of
whatever it tells you to take a picture
of and whoever takes that the picture of
that thing first wins and it will notify
everyone that you won or lost and then
it will take you back to the homepage so
it's kind of like blazing fast machine
learning image recognition scavenger
hunt that to comply with your friends or
anything throughout the world so if any
of you would like to play yeah all right
do it bones up hey so yeah let's go
ahead and do our elegant
so it's si si si - P iccs sick - pics
dotnet la vie comm sick fix don't know
and so you can once you get there you
can click join a random game no sorry
sick pics it's just ELC right - see -
see right there I might consider an
easier spelling alright so it looks like
we have six players in this game all
right
are you guys in good to go yeah I would
go ahead and start all right we got to
take a picture of ketchup oh oh
I lost aa winner who won I lost two
maybe they're in the kitchen all right
[Laughter]
you have to take one that is probably
gonna
[Music]
all right so yeah yeah so right now
anyone can create a game and when you
join a game you just join any kind of
random game so yeah what we tried to do
was I make sure to clear out for the
demo and get the game going so but yeah
anyone with the the URL and just go
ahead and create a game and anyone can
join and then whoever creates the game
has the control to start and so right
now what we have in our database as the
options are to catch up in a coffee so
that we know that we have it but yeah
you with clarify API we could add all
kinds of things with all kinds of
different models so yeah alright worried
that you might if you know if you open
it up you might end up with you know
requests for images in there yeah so the
images don't images are all local so
we're not doing anything with the images
we're not sending them and the ones in
the in our database are just a coffee
and a ketchup not like a pickup truck on
fire what other kinds antigens do you
think you'd load in there to kind of
expand the skill for the game what other
kind of images yeah
do you have an example or a thought or
so dog dog oh yeah so really it's we're
kind of just limit all we're limited by
is that clarify API so right now our
model we have a model of the food model
and we just have ketchup in coffee but
yeah we could take a picture of a pickup
truck on fire yeah not to not open up
the ability to load photos it's we do we
would control like what's available to
be done did yeah the scavenger hunt fix
it yeah and then right now so like oh
the whole game is client based in terms
of like determining whether you want or
not so which is it's kind of fun
with just the fact that we can have but
almost the whole game client side which
is kind of a lot of fun yeah what's the
obviously it has to like a real-time
component so like what did you use for
that
yeah so we used to Sarah so Sarah's I
mean for everyone anyone listening who
doesn't know yet
you know time a it's a graphical API or
a back-end database that has a real-time
capability so that's that's exactly what
we chose to build the game you know yes
that's like one of the prime application
support yeah so one of the examples we
would set for example showing the number
of people that are in the game subscribe
to the users that have a game ID of the
game that you you just creator the game
that you're a part of and so yeah any
time that the Postgres database changes
you automatically get those those
changes yeah whenever someone wins we're
just like we said the games it's
completely client base so whenever
someone updates the state you know in
react that they won we just update that
in the database so none of no one's
gonna take a picture something weird and
put it and pushed our database yeah yeah
so and then we also subscribe to the
status of the game so if when it's
pending and someone pushes start the
game then it will update for everyone
the fact that it's started in progress
and then when someone wins it updates to
say that the game is finished and who
the youth the winner was so yeah we
could we could expand to you know have
user names or names or also like you can
choose which game that you want to join
perhaps a lot of different ways we could
expand up that way how we want the
development process like I guess how did
you decide what you're gonna build so we
started yeah we started we I think we
had the api's in mind already like
clarify and nasarah like they had like
we just kind of thought about the
possibilities and so we decided a game
because I mean it's fun to make games
right and like also when do you make
something that's like something no one
here has ever done something exactly
like this before right and so we're all
thinking creatively and everything and
so it helped us I mean it pushed us you
know I mean so that has but one of the
reason we picked it and uh but where's
the development process where you
started off me we just we initially
started off with a Gatsby
the graph you all implementation there
is real easy to use in it that develop
between is pretty fast but we ran into
several problems one being that Gatsby
does get Gatsby doesn't handle mutations
subscriptions anything that's not a
query very well and so we switched over
to cracked up and then we're using
Apollo as Sara clarify API and klunder
got an area we're sending our pictures
to cloud there and then we're alright
thank you for the wonderful done well
thanks for answering there are many
questions very exhaustive answers by the
way you put a lot of thought into the
tools that you chose thank you
I'm pretty impressed how are you all
feeling I think it's really interesting
to hear sort of what the process is that
people are using and how some teams are
really going hard at the beginning yeah
at the planning process and kind of
making sure that they're building
something up front that's gonna be
useful I think I see that dig maybe like
society you know when I was when I was
in it's a much more mature process that
people seem to be undertaking I suppose
just like I think will be cool to you
know
try and put them all together using it
strictly based on images right back to
that is before api's were there days
like that nice fluffy discs with first
yeah we are to play around when I was a
kid you had to build your own computer
[Laughter]
yeah I'm trying to be good with names
okay well thank you so much for building
samay zhing project that vaulted you to
Florio floor right above us all there is
is a roof deck Wow yeah it was a
catapult
we heard that if we lose you're gonna
cap to keeping in keeping with our
double dare theme all right welcome it's
so wonderful to have you both up here
perhaps you could just tell us a little
bit about yourself your background how
you all met what brought you here okay
so my name is fáááing I flew in from
Houston on Friday just in Texas
I started free coke camp about two years
ago because I wanted to learn a little
bit more my day jobs actually in
corporate finance but I see the
potential for the future and I would
like to be able to work it more into my
career my name is Colin I live here in
Oakland currently I maintain a PHP app
for a construction company that's
working on the BART extension to San
Jose on a contract basis I would like to
be doing a job
javascript thing on more of a full-time
basis we met the day before Friday yeah
on discord in the in the channel to do
to meet right and that's the second team
that made it all the way here that had
actually met and talked Friday night so
preparation planning definitely seems to
work okay great well perhaps you could
go ahead and tell us a little bit about
smartypants
and so we're team smartypants cookie
like the teapot song and panel jeopardy
we built this app because every year
there's more than 300,000 people who'd
like to qualify for the show but only
400 people actually make it now this
means that it's actually harder to get
on Jeopardy than into Harvard
I decided on Monday that I would like to
audition for Jeopardy but in looking
online I couldn't find any user-friendly
or modern resources so when we came here
this is what we decided to build so when
you look at it you're presented with a
question the category and the value of
the question so in the City of Yuma and
this state has the record of record
average of four-thousand 55 hours of
sunshine each year any guesses Arizona
I'm sorry what is Arizona so when you
type in the correct answer it increases
your bank to 200 which was the worst of
the I think it's 100 for the worth of
the question yeah that's 200 yeah so
then it automatically advances you to
the next question now for this one let's
say we don't know we don't want to be
docked we just hit enter to move on so
no change now in this third one or
feeling confident we're gonna take a
guess and you guys will take a guess and
what we'll find is when it's wrong the
answer will show up below but you also
lose money in your bank well now that
you have the answer you say okay let me
type in the answer maybe it'll take it
we can't cheat on this what happens is
when you hit enter no points no docking
move on we found that this app will
solve the real-life problem of we could
take it on the go
it'll be mobile friendly and it has the
capability to be a PW a powered by
Gatsby we built smartypants
using Gatsby so that's react material UI
neckla phi and fauna our first challenge
was loading up the fauna database we
used the fauna importer command-line
tool right away this game was an issue
that seems to have something to do with
file format even though our JSON data
validated just fine daiba at fauna was
super helpful he was kind enough to
actually go on their internal slack
channel and follow up with seek help and
follow up with me in an e-mail it turned
out what we needed was just a single
flag on the command line I was just
missing an option once we had that
option it worked fine we loaded up 610
sample questions that's ten shows worth
out of our total set of 200,000 real
world historic jeopardy questions that
we downloaded the next step was to wire
up that phone a database to netwo Phi
using natla Phi's lambda function
service this gave us three issues first
of all in terms of development
production parity we had to run a server
to run the functions in development
whereas in production they're on the
same domain
so then proxying to that server in
Gatsby eluded us at first the second
thing the Tamil file format gave us some
issues we were putting sensitive data in
there we were putting API keys in there
and so we didn't want a version control
it so then we were like how do we get
that on net Liffe I remove the API keys
and use natla Phi's interface for
environment variables like Heroku and
the third thing was that gatsby and
building on the backend didn't have
access to window that
so we eventually figured out that we
needed to fetch polyfill in all of these
I have to get a give a huge shout out to
Sean at net loaf I who was super
generous and super patient he basically
sat with us and paired with us through
all of these problems he seems to like
share our Stoke at every success point
on all of these in resolving all of
these issues and a couple more really it
was about simplified as simple as
possible use case and console.log that's
something that I would say to other
freaking camp learners so especially
people who are just starting out
simplify simplify simplify and then get
some output as soon as possible
console.log it overall our biggest
sticking point was wiring up all these
api's together I spent all day yesterday
and an hour of this morning just getting
these various api's to work together and
to get a build that would deploy so that
took away a lot of time from actually
building UI from actually building react
components now that I've done at once
though I would definitely go back I
would definitely use nullify and this
host of services again so for future
applications for the jeopardy specific
we want to add more gameplay options but
I think we have an opportunity to also
use this as a framework so I used to
teach English to elderly Iranian
immigrants who were trying to qualify
for citizenship so you could take this
this framework all you need is your own
phone a key and an appropriately
formatted set of questions in JSON
format and you could upload those to
your own phone a database and then you
could make something like a citizenship
quiz app that you could take on the go
use at home at work on the bus etc
right yes sounds like you all learned
like ideas about I don't know opening it
up to be a multiplayer contest or end
users can submit new questions or that
kind of thing for end-users submitting
questions if we're connecting to the
Jeopardy historic database I think maybe
not but for the expansions with using
different frameworks yes in terms of
other players we toured what the idea of
doing user authentication with profile
with Stas your strengths and categories
leaderboard but what's the limited
amount of time that we had this weekend
we've opened up an old issue and Army
Post work on it in the future okay I
would definitely say that user
identities on persisting data would be
one of our next steps so us I mean I
think one of the things everybody loved
liked liked about this egg was that you
scoped it very well so you can easily
see adding that in the future right but
starting out with building something
that in itself works and gives that yet
before worrying about that it's really
good approach Thanks
yeah the core gameplay is there what are
some other things that you did early on
to kind of try and scope the project or
divide up the work or do the planning
before you actually started writing code
about how we want the basic UI to look
at potential gameplay formats I would
pick a couple and then how we would
maybe do users and how we'd split it up
so UI UX reacts and then more of the
backend linking of the different api's
and from our very first contact I would
say we immediately started talking about
what MVP looked like what our literal
minimal scope look like and then
actually we have a teammate who can't be
here because he's at work he so I said
it took away time from working on the UI
he actually was working on like basic UI
without being wired up to any back-end
yesterday while we were doing the API
wire up stuff so so you were able to
work in tandem and not block one another
totally yeah
you have any other questions you're
calling up a great up would you keep
working on it afterwards or do we
already hit that like are you thinking
about Express yeah we have like at least
two or three issues that aren't very far
off for us that I think we could get to
really quickly and I would say when
people look for jobs after freako camp
they say build your portfolio don't just
build what's on the course we built
what's your passion project and I think
I found mine in this one and just one
last question when are you planning to
apply to to be on Jeopardy I don't know
I have a lot of studying but first I
need to build this app Wow
pretty exciting too again like if you're
doing a game the single-player
experience the first thing you feel when
you think the game up matters so much to
the success of the game yeah so like
theta you can scope your app and leave
out like so much of the art have you
left and still get your gameplay done
yeah what's the first game of any of you
creative to cheer I mean everyone's had
to create a game that's right the first
is I've always been like the tutorial of
doing the kissing kissing on balloon
created like a Star Trek next generation
quiz game first but like high pressure
was like somehow I didn't know that I
was gonna have like a whole bunch of
people who were you know from overseas
in my office like learning the
technology and that morning so I woke up
and got to work and here's all these
people and they don't really speak
English and they need to learn no sequel
and so I've got the monitor up with my
editor and I was like let's make a game
nice yeah I also ended up in your
canteen mr. David oh yeah live stream
alright well next up we have the this
Jam
busy busy yeah thank you visit jam and
so so thrilled to have you all here very
impressed with your application we can't
wait to see it well we can't wait
because first we were gonna learn a
little bit about you all we'll start
here with Zubin and then we'll go in
clockwise order can I hear real quick
what was it about our president
impressed you so many things but so many
things yeah yes it's a very impressive
application and you know the animation
oh wait so for a wax politically about
your app all that for this don't see it
zooming take it away hey my name is eben
I'm actually from Melbourne Australia I
was here at work and I'd reached out
Quincy got a ticket because I really
wanted to be part of this I'm a frico
account student in fact free code camps
that have rescued me from from deep
depression because I couldn't figure out
how to code before pretty good guy like
I'd given up cloths and then thanks for
people I really got back on and been
upward since I'm Sean I was born and
raised in Bay I was originally an ite
and I since left my job to pursue
learning code full-time and I've been
doing it about a year now and this is my
first hackathon so excited to learn hi
my name is Elon I'm originally from
Colombia I've been in the Bay Area for
about five years
and I'm a firm a developer and I love
the idea of gem stack so but it's real
to be here Angela my name is Juan I'm
from Massachusetts and I'm currently a
student my name is Sarah I just moved to
San Francisco a couple months ago to
also attend rhythm school and this was
my first hackathon so it's great to be
here I learned a lot great
yeah my name is David Lam and I'm a
frico Campus student and I just I've
been going through the curriculum the
full stack the new full stack web
development curriculum and I learned so
much going through this project that you
wouldn't learn by herself because it's
just a completely different setting I
mean you think you know everything
already but once you work with other
people you don't know no it's great to
work with other people with different
backgrounds and you need to like just
work with other people do you think like
you think you know it all but you don't
you can always work with more people in
yeah I love these guys great well we're
to the audience come to hackathons put
yourself out there get experience
working with a team all right so let's
see it all right you ready
yeah all right so I'll quickly introduce
mrs. Jam so we like to think of easy jam
is it's time to do to forget about
Pokemon capture data instead you know
when you when you come to a hackathon
there's a real problem invisible data
you know who's who's there what level of
experience do they have do they need two
team members or not how do they find
team members and then there's a problem
for actual organizers and the you know
the product managers and others who run
the sponsorship side of things right so
the API and things well that oh the API
is available who's using it whether they
had an easy time but not such an easy
time using it why did they choose to use
that this is all really valuable
information from the organization
authorities so eventually what we've
gotta make busy jerem do is also be a
matchmaking service for attendees and at
the same time provide really high
quality data to organizers and the and
the sponsors when we got together we
realized it was such a pain because
this action knew each other it was hard
to find team members and that's right
away was an immediate in a problem that
we wanted to try and solve that's where
this started and then we said before we
start building or writing in code let's
actually validate this so we went and
had a whole bunch of interview spoke to
a bunch of people interviewed each other
and others who'd attended identified the
basic problem statement then started
prioritizing what we wanted to build
research the api's built it you know it
was a great experience and so what busy
gem does now as you can see it's a
pretty straightforward dashboard we've
got all that is real-time data and so
we've used Gatsby Annette with high of
course we also use foam spray so that's
actually real data from attendees at
this at this hackathon so David if you
want to go to the entry form so that's
actually we can actually start punching
in data right now and David will do that
as I speak but it asks a bunch of
questions and you can see that it'll
update so when we go back to the
dashboard you will see for example if
David were to say that he's now very
experienced in Java it'll show that
there was another person who's increases
you know level of experience and let's
say Java we can add stuff fairly quickly
to this that also talks about what's
what API is they use right now we're
using forms free for the actual phone
and we're also using foam streets
backend with an API endpoint from where
we can retrieve the data we're using
Netta fire to actually run the
continuous deployment and you know the
necklace I login page is also possible
but that makes sense only once we ever
probably use it in a mobile and stuff
like that right now you can see that
when he's when he submits it it'll say
what I want is I don't want I want to be
able to see that made a change in the
data so what I'm gonna do is I need to
make another tab and cuz I don't want to
like dummy data so so that when I do
something that actually the change is
reflected so right now the percentage of
mail you can see is generous
66 to 4% so once I enter my form data it
should theoretically increase 60 C 6.2
by whatever one of whatever is the total
so as long as larger than that so we'll
know it's different sixty six point yeah
so just actually doesn't work
- yeah mark so Mayo was sixty six point
two is sixty six point seven so there
was a dip so we can see that there is a
change in the data yeah
and what we did was we had members of
our team
walk up to other attendees and
personally delivered this kind of survey
conduct the kind of survey ask them
these questions
some of us ask them the questions I just
gave them the links like hey can you
could you do this for us and you know
yeah nice yeah they'll say yeah of
course why not it's just a couple
minutes it's simple form but yeah the
root problem as Zubin mention was when
we all came in we didn't know who each
other are and we could use this data to
if we have this data beforehand we would
know better about other attendees oh you
work with JavaScript I work with
JavaScript too it's just easier way to
know who each other are it would have
been helpful if we had this before but
we made it now we can use this for
future hackathons anything we can expand
it to wherever we want but we can do
that all in two days so we just did
where we could the basic so one of our
users actually really cool suggestion
they like you know we've done to do
three of the attack but we don't have a
profile that says that that's actually a
fantastic talk about you know user
generated product about it right
somebody actually okay so you know if
David's done three hackathons these are
the dates these you know this is the
link it's a great platform for hackathon
standardized there and the products like
there's so much stuff we could use and
I'm like other you know we wanted to be
careful not to make it a trivial cut so
the application we want to make it
something that could prove that the API
is rolled to capable of supporting a b2b
use case which i think is really
important from a monetization point
point of view for the API certainly so
we said okay if this was a serious
product could it actually you know could
the API is actually supported and they
absolutely can so that's great
excellent thank you for the demo it's
questions have you thought about how to
get the word out to me this is like
hailer made for press releases and
not to get on a livestream you know
always make it we can always make it
better I know it looks kind of it looks
simple right now but we can to make it
like more interactive so that once you
enter like once you answer your data you
can know exactly like you animate so you
can see it a change in difference at the
data so it doesn't look like I have to
refresh the page but yeah let's we can
look over to data and this kind of data
could be interesting to a data scientist
who stays data how thing any we've none
of us had kind of background data
scientists but I've heard of what they
do I mean I know what their rows it's
different than us we're doing
development we make the structure we use
the structure and build off the product
but to this a data scientist they could
see oh you know this this event had many
attendees who had foregrip who had
experience with JavaScript right like 20
beginners 18:38
intermediate and five advanced and not
many not many Ruby developers so
probably not many who develop on most
things I'll just jump it actually
because that's an interesting question
do you how would you guys want to use
this because you know we've asked a lot
of the participants we haven't had a
chance to ask people who actually
produce the api's and the many how would
you like to use something like this so
how would you see this be useful you
mentioned a little bit matchmaking which
would you need to go deeper so you'd
model the individual correct yeah that
was a feature that we talked about in
our planning process but you know we
were thinking about what's our Minimum
Viable Product and then a period we are
kind of on the wish list we have to be
really strict about prioritizing but you
know that's the perfect setting for a
graph you're kind of you know back-end
yeah hey what do you other it is at what
point that you guys all decide like this
is what we're going to build this time I
think I think we had like this basic
concept pretty quickly like within five
minutes of discussing our plan yeah and
then we
I've had a sort of like spiderweb
conversation I was like what about these
features we made a list and then
probably took another 20 minutes to
really narrow down like this is our
Minimum Viable Product and I think one
of the big challenges we faced is even
when we were starting out we started out
like a static JSON file that we were
loading the data from and then we wanted
to transition to the live update that
API so a lot of us are really new to get
and so having kind of different branches
where we were experimenting with
different things created some merge
conflicts so it was actually great to
have the opportunity to kind of work
through that together know you asked how
it the idea started right and it it
actually started and when we all sat
down after and we had the brainstorming
idea and Alon he just threw it out there
so you know we should we should start
asking people around I mean he had he
had the initiative to just bring it up
and we were all listening we were
thinking if it's a good idea we thought
about it and you said yeah let's just
let's do it yeah I have to definitely
command your execution because it takes
I can speak from experience having build
projects where you go around you ask
everybody back it takes a lot of work
and a lot of courage to approach your
peers and stick and iPad in their hand
or however you were going about doing it
so yeah it's really impressive you might
scroll it down just a little bit to the
years of coding so according to hype
form which is what we use to collect
data for yeah
giving up the tickets the tickets were
free but you had to go through this
tutorial this chance text tutorial I
created and one of the questions was how
long you been coding and the median
number of months was 16 16 months coding
which is right there yeah yeah so
between one and two years so yeah that's
the representation between yeah so it's
pretty cool that your data is so
representative is my unit which was like
a thousand points yeah yeah there's a
wide range of experience and there's
something that worse works less than six
months so you know if you're attending
someone maybe
your experience and you want to group up
with someone experienced as well so you
know you know you guys can get started
real quick right away maybe you know you
want to grow up with someone with less
experience so you can mentor them that's
a possibility too if you knew if people
who signed up have less experience you
could link them up with people who are
looking for people looking and I think
also like in just promoting you know
future hackathons you know for me this
was my first hackathon and I was kind of
wondering whether I should sign up or
not am I gonna be ready and so seeing
you know that Owen the last hackathon
there were people who had less than six
months of coding experience could be
your way to make you know people feel
comfortable in the future were there
questions you wanted to put in but left
out because you didn't have too many
questions absolutely we wanted to
actually talk about stuff my will you
know hopefully we were thinking if we
could collect the data fairly close to
the end we knew that's a high pressure
time it's gonna just don't take a hike
right but the idea was you know which of
the api's you to use and actually just
have a chat but like we've got the phone
widget I just hadn't productionize that
that bit because you know we didn't want
like that add that there were couple of
questions like that how many have you
done before and stuff laughs so we just
want to prioritize what we know people
will be happy to share very quickly it
takes less than 30 seconds to collect it
either when we went back but Butthead
that kind of stuff yeah yeah this part
of the ideation process we talked about
if we want it to be more individual
contributor like a member or someone
attending focused or like sponsor focus
right so with once we decide on that we
were also able to kind of press through
the questions and be like okay this is
something more that like Nell if I would
want to know right this is more
something someone like me Sarah or
Yolanda know we did that as well well
I'm very impressed for this and I could
definitely see this as being kind of
like one of the major components of
essentially a larger open-source
hackathon toolkit that hackathon
organizers could use and one of the
things we've built over the weekend at
free code camp was that leaderboard
can't we call it the project index cuz
it was an actual leaderboard but it you
know this Plus that which is open-source
I think they put the MIT life
and all these other tools that we could
potentially comp with you know we could
potentially have like a whole suite when
you want to have a hackathon clone this
repo Quincy actually I want to bring us
up what we did was actually something
you did earlier earlier simpler before
like this year which was like every time
you sign up sign into freako cam page
there's a survey and a link with the
header it says click here work we're
doing a math survey of all the
developers please spend you know give us
five minutes that's what that's exactly
what we did we asked people you know
their background just demographic
information that's just what you did and
then we we just brought alive to the
today yeah
the location allottee of it and the
temporality of it are definitely
interesting aspect and what what David's
referencing is the 2018 new coder survey
which we interviewed 30,000 people we
had them all fill out a survey we're
currently crunching those numbers but
we're gonna release that as a giant
public data set hopefully in a month or
so and you know people aren't interested
in that data right we're gonna get it
out there hey oh thank you so much thank
you
zooming thanks ever David thank you
Sarah thanks tree one come on Sean
you all are great you've done some
amazing work here and thanks again I
hope you'll stick around he's just a
break so you gotta talk downstairs thank
you thanks very much thank you
alright and I think we 6-7 team number
seven where in the world they should be
coming alright welcome thank you for
waiting in the hall it is thrilling to
introduce you all we were very impressed
with your application we can't wait to
see it before we do let's go around and
talk about each of you and your
background and what drew you to this
active not sure my name is tatis i-i've
been a full-stack developer for a few
years but recently left my company to go
to work on a jam stag app a business
built around a jam staff of my own so
that's what I'm doing right now and I'm
here because Jeff stack drew me the the
conference Jimmy to to San Francisco and
wanted to stick around for the hackathon
as well so I'm Jeff I am a freelance web
developer I've been working for about
seven eight years various contracts and
I've been really into the jam stack
because I love working on the front-end
part of things and I like working on the
interface and what you see and you know
if I can have api's take care of the
backend it's great so I I wanted to meet
more people that are all about that kind
of stack and see where I can go with it
all right my name is Gavin field I'm a
front-end developer I work at Frontier
Airlines in Denver Colorado
yeah I'm Rhonda the jams tech is another
you know front-end developer looking to
outsource some of that back-end work so
that I can do what I love and make
actually quit they're fun cool exciting
and really powerful yeah
my name is Tyler Vick I live in Columbus
Ohio I am an aerospace engineer turned
data scientist turned web developer and
I've been using net Liffe I in my
freelance work and I couldn't miss the
chance to come to a sponsor James tech
conference and hackathon Rayo sounds
like you all have a lot of jam stack
experience between the for you awesome
yeah if you want to take it away with it
down yeah so well I guess yeah we're
team where in the world and we are going
to be doing a live game show with
everybody watching so if you're watching
please join in check there's a link on
the discord 4002 whit world's dot live
yes we bought a domain don't worry it's
hosted on nullify please join that link
and so we're gonna get started here but
and you and if it's taken you a minute
you can join in the middle is fine you
just go here put in your name it's gonna
show up on the leader board so pick a
name that you'll recognize yes now we're
in the lobby if you look in the top left
there you can see the the player count
increasing live no need to refresh it'll
keep up updating it has more players
join looks like we've got you might want
to drag the window just a little bit
hopefully it's 18 Wow yeah I think we're
about ready let's kick it off we're
gonna we're gonna kick it we're using a
little nullify function with our there's
gonna be an image and then there's a map
you want to pick like point a pin on the
map where you think that image is that's
basically it we're in the world of
images all right be ready take it off
here okay let's do it
so now everyone sees this and if it you
know the mobile should see the map below
the image and if you're on a desktop
you'll see a look and see where I'm
guessing so now know jeff has guessed
he's submitted everyone else is getting
their their submissions in and as
everyone else is guessing we're gonna
see them pop up live here wherever
wherever everyone thinks it is and then
you also do make this feel a little
smaller we can see the scores on the
right as well oh yeah don't forget to
hit submit because if you don't hit
something you just won't get you just
won't get the we won't record your
submit your yes but don't worry run it
again we can run another game in a
second here but you can see the scores
are popping up there on the right as as
everyone's done and the game is over
it's you get 30 seconds and that was
that's the game we can play
let's do another one do another one for
those of you who missed might might have
had anything unclear with the
instructions so play again the button
pops up you should have a button up here
or in your mobile app somewhere to click
play again to play again so now we'll be
in the waiting room
oh man you got 21 now all right ready to
play another
here we go we're live where in the world
Jeff yes nice middle of the United
States
oh here's any water there Jeff
Colorado maybe maybe we've got Oh
everyone so far away was all over the
place here what's going on it looks like
a golden gate bridge we jammed a lot
together
was very instrumental and that we were
we're making use of fuel subscriptions
and it made it really easy to set those
up the WebSocket endpoint that they
automatically generated for us and I
made that really easy nullify we
obviously deploy it on notify and then
also use a lot of nullify functions so
that's sad when when we're one we're
waiting to get the game started we have
a little like on our github readme we
set up a little admin panel that makes
it easy to start a game with different
with different images that we have lined
up I curated to go and then on the
bottom we have all the little pieces
little moving pieces that helped make it
happen so it's a react app we're using
Apollo on the client-side to do the
graph QL integration with Asura Heroku
is hosting our asura instance and the
Google Maps API provided the map and the
some of the slack in github and two
languages for starting development
process essentially yeah great good demo
I'll write all just together as a team
and how did you choose what you were
gonna build well we all kind of met each
other at the conference we were all at
the conference and sort of we're
mutually connected there
and we formed our team yesterday morning
at breakfast and threw out some ideas
and we just chose one shortly after the
keynote yeah we were we kind of the way
we described what we counted on is that
we wanted to do two things we wanted to
show the power show the work show the
power of the jam stack and also show
people the world that was how what was
kind of the develop I guess the like
product development process like did you
you know did you do any drawings did you
kind of like do any I don't know case
user study kind of thing or anything
like that or to just dive right in the
right code we did some like data
modeling we had I brought in a little
mini whiteboard this guy so we did some
data modeling so that way we could have
like some sample data in our database
and it was really good for just kind of
driving a discussion of like oh like we
didn't think about this concept the same
way so then we were able to kind of
bridge those gaps before we started
writing a single line of code or think
you have a single mock yeah and then we
split up like someone working on the
data setting up the database and then
working on the front end we decided to
do a pair programming history didn't
want to like too much confusion and we
could just put two minds and under one
computer and that worked really well I
think that was especially like the
Ramones were like I like somebody was
really honed in on something needed to
get something done maybe were you know
if you would like an hour before or some
deadline and then but because we pair
program most of it we were always able
to rely on some other person who knew
each piece of the like all these
different pieces that were working
together so we could always have like
kind of like a fallback plan in case
like the person who had had actually
been doing the driving wasn't available
at the moment yeah what features are
your just outside of scope that you
would add if you had more time the two
big ones that we had in mind were the
ability for users to kind of like
facilitate these games in the sense that
like uploading the photos okay we think
we were one of our inspirations with
trivia HQ so we like the concept of
having one game going on but it'd be
nice if kind of with our show the world
kind of mission if users could like say
like I you know I really I think this
place is really cool and I want more
people to know about it let me submit a
photo of that place and let's play a
game about it and then the other one is
kind of have like a different
potentially like different localizations
for the games so like everyone can play
a world game but if we were to like say
let's play like a San Francisco kind of
game then there'd be like the like level
of granularity I wish the photos would
come in and then people could play would
be only relevant to people who like
really know the area so then just kind
of like different levels of localization
would be interesting as well yeah that's
I could see this being really popular my
parents love that tribute game and they
only play together and I could
definitely see this being like a
community thing like San Francisco has
so many distinctive landmarks and even
little benches that people might be able
to recognize you know yeah with that
long term maybe we could introduce
training of machine learning some of
these images maybe do like a what in the
world app where you could look at
certain things and see what those things
are but yeah that's kind of a far goal
all right well thank you so much for you
coming in and giving this awesome down
welcome thanks for coming out yeah I'm
building this it's you use a lot of
different tools
yeah I'm just I think it's always
awesome when something is its scope just
right so you can actually like really
end up with with a working demo and a
lab domain and and launch something to
the world in a weekend yeah I think to
be honest like with all the tools it
makes that easier like I'm surprised
that in two days we could do this but I
think like all of these tools terrify us
or react I mean it's like yeah pretty
cool I think I would have spent a half a
hackathon just putting up a website now
is like another five buy domain deploy
Oh
on with anything it's a brave new world
cool thank you thanks yeah pleasure
gentlemen I'll see you downstairs yeah
that's good thank you
yep all right well we've had very
in-depth talks with seven different
teams and we are going to discuss some
ourselves the judging team I just want
to give a final shout out net laughs I
for everything they're doing for
providing the fundamental technology
that this is higher Agathon Ezra on
thank you so much Matt for your
sponsorship and for being on the judging
panel Thanks thank you Chris and
everything you all are doing over at
fana very excited about it we're
interested in exploring it ourselves
free coking thank you so much Cole you
an incredible interviewee we're gonna
post that interview with Kohler
thanks to forms for you for sponsoring
and everybody who's watching have a
beautiful evening and
[Music]